受けて本日3月31日 youtube の方でチャンネル登録者数を見てみますと
なんとアン略版人を突破しましたああいうのです
多分なんですけど日本発です日本発チャンネル登録者300万人越えということで
ちょっと今日はですねまずは本当にそのネル登録してください皆様そして
いつも僕のまずでしょうもない動画を見てくださる皆さんは本当にありがとう本当に
ありがとうございますそこまで来れたのは本当に皆様のお陰ですこれがもうわけが
わかんない動画があると思います3年末にもありましたトリビアプロ額な言葉に日目は
外すこともあると思いますが
だからもよろしくお願いしますじゃあ僕は西条思ったんですけど詐欺すぐお米通って
言われることが別あちゃ多いめっ
多いんですよ誕生日から集まってくる誕生日2月強く誕生日誕生日おめでとありがとう
ございます単位取れました
卒業確定おめでとありがとうございますチャンネル登録者数が日本一になりましたお
めでとうありがとうございます息様式風にせず8日初業をみるとありがとうございます
そしてチャンネル登録者ため軍におめでとうございますありがとうございます
何かあっん
しますしかしますてくれちょっとビビってるなんだろうねすごい今ピークを着てます
それなら2個と続いた後は多分落ちると思うんでいつでも落ちてもいいぐらいの気持ち
ずっとこれからも頑張らせていただきますでねなんかすげーいいことばかりじゃん
はじめみたいに陥ってる人はいると思うんですけどもそうじゃないっすよいいこと
ばっかりやると思ったら大違い
僕がいつも使ったりこのカメラ eos 70 d がキー
と言われましたありがとう
ません
スペースでいくつ今この充電してたマックスの充電ですね入れます
電源付きます
ブーブーいい
いいことばっかりじゃないんですよ同じ木に2つもほどが買われるレンズとカメラは
300万人ってうれしいんですけどずっと使ってたカメラが壊れたりしてなんか複雑な
心境ですはじめ一つは4月入る前に300万人釣り池たんだよ本当に良かったですね
たいことたくさんあるんですけれどもそうやってた僕はすごい面白いと思うんですけど
も
見ている子どもたちと学校
当然たする場にして危なかったりすると危ないんで名人が多いってなるとですね
自分の好きなことバンバンやってるだけでもダメだなと思ってきてそう言うとかきょう
つけていかなきゃなと思っておりますそれでもハメを外すときは外すけどな
雨風んですけどもね今まで通り何か好きなことってただやってるだけだとやっぱダメな
んだよなかなかね周りに気を遣いだが
あちょっと頑張っていきますではないかネギなどとしてあぁ
た平気なことしてということも考慮しながら今後頑張っていきますで何かねちょっと
最近年言いたいことがあったんですよ
小学生の夢ツラに目第一サッカー選手第2位社台サイン有
1バー日本の将来を危惧する人多数まじかー
いろんな人の意見を見るとですね102みたいな人が多いですね
世も末だ日本の未来が心配だとかよだか終わってるとかいいと思いますよ
ユーチューバー
なりたいと思ってくれて僕も嬉しいです何を心配しているかというとそれもありなん
ですね勉強しなくなるんじゃねーか見たいなとかですけど真剣に youtube に
動画を投稿
してるからもうユーチューバーになるから勉強しませんって言ってる子供
んねフォア小学生それは違うぞそれが違うぞ
マジでとりあえず今日の動画は雄2羽になりたくて勉強しないよマイナーにいうことが
ある僕の実家の話をしましょう
あの言っちゃなんですけど僕の実家は結構厳しかったです
じいちゃんばあちゃんも言って母さん父さんおいてねぼく講座
所から結構今 youtube でやってるようなことをすぐやりたくて
いろんなバカなことやってました小学校のときたらそれを全部家で怒られてました家の
中でね講師や遊びしようとしたんですけど家の中で火遊びしたのがバレた瞬間も家族を
殺されそうに月って結構ねこっぴどく怒られたことが何度もあったんですけど今結構に
厳しかったっぽいなんですよねあの自分で言っちゃおかしいんですけどケッ
ちゃんとう
育てが出ていると思いますかずくん大切だし良い奴が bs だとかスピート立つ
なんて後稼ぐ家族です
そういうで結構しつけがしっかりした厳しいかでて育っちゃってそのなんか溜め込んで
ダンサーやっぱりこうだから今年てめちゃくちゃされて大暴れ
な気持ちを持ったのま僕が大学に進んでしまって大学に進んで一人暮らしを始め
ましたこれは何を意味するかは来るかそう
始め薩摩鍛造だ動画根元からこんな馬鹿っていうわけじゃなくて馬鹿だけどね
家に行って父さん母さんの家族に怒られてできなかったことを一人暮らしになって呪縛
から解放されて大学生活するに解き放ってしまったり
そういうイメージで僕多分でしょう2個と結構真面目だったんですよ済みだったんです
けどその大学に行って一人で暮らして
ますで誰も通じている人がいない暴言がない遊び放題
0感じで始めたのがいうツールでしたなんて何だろうねその子供の時が行われてでき
なかったこと僕が大人になって自己責任で youtube でやってるっていう
イメージです
責任は自分に来るからね僕は今自分でしたいことただ動画にしてるだけです
なのでそこのユーチューバーになりたいと思ってる人今はちょっと早いんじゃないか
2番になりたいから勉強しませんっていうおかしいと思うよねこれ泣けないんですけど
とりあえずねべインチは絶対そういった方にかっこいいし俺みたいな頭悪いあったら
いいんですけどまぁその昭通こそ勉強して国立第二部に入って卒業いましたんだ
ユーチューバーに憧れるのは凄い僕はうれしいしありがたいことですそしてぜひとも
なってほしいというのは大学カーズ
仕事を始めてからか分からないんですけどやることやってから youtube 外れ
たら
いいのかなっていうか思います難しいねちょっと上手いこと言えないんですけどね小
学校の頃僕同じ事言ってても何だこのクソガキっとやって終わってたかもしれない
それず小学生勉強しといた方がいい勉強した方が説得力があるなまで小学生のみなさん
ぜひユーチューバーになってくださいでもやることはやりましょう
かっこいい墓を目指しましょう俺みたいな
はいそれ行けずが続くなんて言えなかったんですけどまぁ何が言いたいかというという
中バイクの勉強しないというのは違いますという感じのお話がしたかったですゆ中
バーガーでも仕事3位になったとか嬉しいです受けで今後も弾み冊をよろしくお願いし
ます下から4月那覇やまた来年度もよろしくお願いします
じゃじゃーん